We're reading through this research and we're like, oh shit, I can definitely hack something
I'm hacking on right now with this.
Best part of hacking when you can just, you know, critical think, right?
I'm not sure y'all know this, but two of the most respected hackers in the CTPB community,
Bus Factor and XSS Doctor, are now running monthly hack alongs on the CTPB Discord.
Okay?
You've got to check this out.
CTPB.show/discord.
We find bugs almost every time we hack.
It's crazy.
And oftentimes it's not even the people running the hack alongs.
It's the community members that are hacking along with us.
You definitely increase your chance of finding a bug by being on these hack alongs.
So check them out, CTPB.show/discord.
Join Bus, XSS Doctor and yours truly.
And let's pop some bugs.
All right, let's go.
Back to the show.
All right, man.
Well, we just had a false start where I didn't press the record button.
Yeah, I made so many good jokes.
Oh my gosh.
But we're back.
Guys, this is the Portswigger Top 10 Web Hacking Techniques of 2025 episode.
And guys, I know I complain about it every year, but this episode is a monster to prep for.
Because these are very technical pieces of research.
And now we are going to try to articulate them to you in the audio medium, which is
still challenging after three years.
Yeah, hacking is kind of like text first in the same way that coding is, right?
Yeah.
So it's going to be a beast, but we're going to give it a shot.
There was a lot of other awesome research also in the nominations, which I think
we definitely should go back and review.
I think 163 pieces of research contended this year, which is significantly fewer than 121 that was
submitted last year.
Yeah, you and Brandon should do an episode on that, so.
Yeah, yeah.
Dude, okay.
I see you trying to weasel your way out of that research.
All right.
Well, let's get to it, man.
We've got it kind of divvied up by capability rather than by order.
So what's going to happen is Joseph is going to take 10 and nine.
I'm going to take eight and seven and we're going to kind of go back and forth.
So we're going to jump around a little bit.
But first one up is parser differentials when interpretation becomes a vulnerability
and you're going to take that one, right?
That's right.
Yeah.
So this got 10th place.
It's a video.
It's not like an official white paper or anything like that.
Yeah, it's just a YouTube video.
It was a talk at Offensive Con 25 by Georgian.
But he is a GitLab engineer and it's a pretty, it's a pretty great talk.
I think I really love parser issues.
And so it's the reason I grabbed this one because I got into the doc before Justin did
and was able to snag this one.
So, I mean, you should just go watch the talk to anyone.
I mean, it's not that long.
It's 28 minutes.
And I'm sure if you're watching on 2X, you know, it's even faster.
But what's really neat was that he looked at a bunch of different parser differentials
and he was mostly thinking about them in the differences of like, you know,
if there's a tech stack that has like Go running at one point and then Python later,
how does it handle specifically YAML or actually, sorry, no YAML was one of the later ones.
Yeah, no, YAML was like the bulk of what he found in the end, but he was looking at different
things between like Kubernetes and Java and other things.
But I just wanted to bring to the audience, like basically the lowest hanging fruit here,
like the stuff that's like most valuable to try.
And basically the first one was just parameter injection.
So there was two role parameters.
One was like sending it to admin.
One was just setting it as like role, like an empty list.
And because the parsers handled it separately, it basically bypassed the JavaScript check,
which was checking the second one.
And then whenever it actually got to the Java implementation,
it read like the backend server side code, read the first one, set them to an admin.
And I think I can actually share my screen on that exact screenshot.
Yeah, let me share it real quick for the people who are watching on YouTube.
This one right here.
So this is in a parser differential in HTTP rather than in YAML or something like that?
No, it's JavaScript and Erlang.
I don't know where it was actually, like what repo was in or what project.
Oh, it looks like this is JSON here.
Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
Yeah, it's like a JSON input.
And Erlang, like whenever it's parsing this, it accepts the first role.
But whenever JavaScript is parsing this, it accepts the latter role here.
So for the listeners, basically, it's what I said just a minute ago.
It's just like the key is roles.
And there's two of those keys.
And the first one is a list that includes admin.
And the second one is not.
And so you're able to get, you know, JavaScript saw an empty array, whereas Erlang saw the
underscore admin role and granted that to the user.
So, you know, kind of neat, pretty cool.
We've seen stuff like this before.
The second one, the second example he thought he showed, which I thought was pretty neat,
was a double auth tag, a double authorization header.
I bet this exists in way more places.
So the first one was a none signed fake admin JWT.
And then the second auth header was a legit bear token that the application gave you.
And you could put, exactly, it's really cool.
You could put basically attributes that you want into that first none signed one.
You know, I think all of us have tried this, but I've only ever done it with one, right?
You change the legit one to none signed, you don't do both.
Wow.
Okay, so he's smuggling in a second authorization bearer.
And the middleware, you know, the front piece is checking for that second bearer,
which is a legit JWT signed low priv.
But the back end is actually grabbing the auth bearer that is algorithm none
with all of our stuff in it.
And that's not checking the signature.
It's just accepting all of our crazy attributes.
Yep.
That's exactly right.
Dang, dude.
It's really cool.
Yeah.
And then the rest of this talk is really neat.
It's all about YAML.
And there's a bunch of cool things that YAML had that I didn't know.
So one is this like binary thing.
You can just like prefix a line with like exclamation mark, exclamation mark binary.
And then that key or it's like, sometimes it's key.
Sometimes it's values get like are allowed to be interpreted as base 64 encoded content.
Oh, it's really weird.
So for the listeners, I'm sharing on screen a couple of different things, but he, yeah.
Yeah.
So that, that one is go back to that really quickly.
Okay.
So here we'll hear, let me read this to you.
The bang, the bang, bang binary tag can be used to base 64 encode arbitrary binary data inside of YAML.
So I think this is most useful for like sending in like audio or images or things like that.
Wow.
Yeah.
That makes sense.
So essentially, and you can use that in a key or in a value, right?
So it's like an operation that is being run on top of a, you know, the value that is
being provided in, in YAML here.
So in the example right there that you've got up on the screen, it's saying LANG is Python.
Okay.
It's saying LANG is Python, but then it's doing bang, bang binary.
And then providing the base 64 encoded version of LANG, which is overriding.
Yes.
Oh my God.
And, and then bang binary.
And then it again.
And so the output of this, as you, as you watch here, uh, or as like the listeners
is like, I don't know why this is first and second.
Instead of, he should have kept this going with the same vernacular, but I see what you're saying.
But anyways.
Yeah.
So, so basically you can, you can trick things and then later on he does this other thing with it's, um, merge.
Or actually, so actually I'm, I get this a little conflated because listeners, honestly, I took this
and I told cloud code, extend this research and look for more stuff like this.
There's another thing called merge.
And I can't remember if he used merge or if my cloud code thought of the idea of using merge,
but there, there is a YAML and there's a YAML thing called merge.
Yeah.
I think it's totally my cloud code and not in this talk.
Basically there is a, um, another YAML, um, declarative or whatever it's called function.
That's like a great, or it's less than, less than, and it merges the next key that you have
into the first key.
And this is also very problematic for parser differences.
Um, so anyways, pretty cool talk.
I think people would get a lot out of it.
Um, and you should definitely go watch it.
Dude.
Yeah.
What the heck are these shorthand tags in YAML?
Do you just want to do you want to share?
Do you want me to?
No, no, no, no, no.
You, you go ahead.
I'm just like, you got me nerd sniped a little bit right now.
How, wow.
There's like all sorts of transformations you can do on YAML, man.
There's just going to be an absolute insane number of problems because of this.
Yeah.
This is the table I showed you.
There's lots of crazy stuff too.
Where like, uh, if you put like yes or no, or true or false.
And like in some, it gets interpreted as a string and therefore results out as true,
even though you wrote the word false, but it's a string and strings equate to true.
Like, dude, there's so many YAML parser issues.
And what's what I'm really hopeful on this with, with my own research and finding is that,
in places like GitHub CICD, this will be like mega critical, uh, as far as actual impact.
Wow, dude.
Yeah.
That's sick.
So definitely something to look into there.
I'm very surprised to see that being used in keys as well.
Right.
Cause the, the YAML file that you showed, you know, it defined an attribute laying equals,
whatever the length, um, colon, whatever, but then it provided a binary version of laying.
Right.
And then provided an alternative value.
And then depending on how those are prioritized with the binary decoding, one may do the, the,
you know, tag resolution before parsing the line above it, or it might be after.
That's right.
So, so much opportunity for parser differentials there.
Yes.
That's sick.
Very sick.
Wow.
And, and I just, and you know, of course I love.
AI stuff.
All the AI stuff is marked down to HTML.
Same exact thing.
Right.
A bunch across a bunch of different libraries.
And so I want to actually apply the same research logic that he did.
And that I had cloud code do like, as like a followup to that research,
to the mark down to, um, HTML parser.
So I'll let you know if that finds anything.
Yeah, dude.
It was so funny.
Cause I did the exact same thing that you did with this, which is like,
you were reading through this research and we're like, oh shit.
I can definitely hack something I'm hacking on right now with this.
So you just like, you know, kicked off a cloud code.
And, and I'll, I'll explain the one that I just did later.
But, um, I, I kicked off a, a cloud code instance as well.
And I found a bone while I was reading this research, which is nuts.
Um, so crazy world we're living in here.
It really is.
All right.
Number nine is playing with HTTP2 connect.
I'm going to let you take that.
But first I'm going to jump down to XSS leak leaking cross origin redirects.
And this was kind of a, of an interesting one because, uh, it's called XSS leaks,
but it doesn't have anything to do with XSS.
It's a cross site subdomain leak, which is a variety of excess leak.
Okay.
Um, and essentially what this research is about is leaking cross origin, uh, redirects,
which is a very specific situation.
Uh, it's kind of CTFE to be honest, but, um,
the website is a little CTFE too.
Yeah.
It looks great for all the listeners.
It's like a beautiful, like, um, yeah, purple and black website.
That's like very typical, like hackery.
Yeah.
Terminal vibes.
Uh, yeah.
Um, but, and there are some, some applications for this research, for sure.
Like I've run into a situation where I need to know a sub domain like this, uh, in cloud
environments where it'll generate like an arbitrary sub domain or whatever.
And if you can leak that sub domains, that sub domain itself, then that will be helpful
for like explaining an XSS or something.
Um, but essentially what this writeup is focused on is how do we abuse the Chrome connection pool
to, uh, leak those, uh, cross origin hosts.
And, um, the TLDR behind this is that Chrome has a connection pool cap at 256 concurrent requests
and six requests for a given origin.
Okay.
So what the, um, the attacker here does is he fills all the way up the, uh, Chrome connection
pool and then abuses the order that free spot spots are filled within Chrome.
Okay.
So you might think it's like first in first out.
It's not, that would make too much sense.
The way that Chrome actually does this is it will sort by port scheme and then host, right?
So if you have, let's say you have 255, you know, concurrent requests in the connection pool
and a slot opens up, right?
And there's two requests pending.
Uh, Chrome will first look at the priority of those requests, right?
Which we can override to high using like fetch.
Um, and then it will, you know, if the priority is high for both of them,
then it will then sort by port, then scheme, then host, right?
So the lower port is better.
So if you've got a, uh, request to port 80, that's going to be, uh, prioritized over something
that's, you know, port one, one, three, three, seven or something like that.
Um, but the real magic comes in when you make the port and the scheme the same.
So all you're doing is actually, uh, having Chrome compare the host, uh, lexicographically
and I had to look up that word, Joseph lexicographically, but essentially.
I can't say it.
Yeah.
Well, I was also mispronouncing it.
So I had to look up how to say it, you know, before this episode.
Um, but essentially it's just like an alphabetical order, right?
Um, so if you have a host that, you know, uh, starts with an A or whatever,
that's going to be prioritized over a host that starts with a B, right?
And because of that, you can do a binary search, uh, and figure out whether the request
on, on the cross origin page was issued or was let into the connection pool first
or whether your request was.
So here's how you do that.
Okay.
So first you fill up the connection pool.
Then you use in this scenario, it was a hash change event to trigger a cross origin request.
Okay.
So now that request is requesting to get access to the Chrome connection pool,
but then it cannot.
Right.
And then we also at the same time trigger our guess for what that subdomain might be.
So now there's two requests competing for that, for an open slot in the connection pool.
Then you release one of the, uh, slots in the connection pool
and you trigger how long it takes for your request to go through.
Okay.
Um, and if it's a longer piece, you know, if it takes longer,
then you know that it actually let first the cross origin request through,
and then your request.
Right.
And if it's shorter response time, then it knows that, you know, your request got priority
over the cross origin request.
Right.
Which means your, um, request was lexicographically smaller than the one that, uh, you wanted to
trigger on the cross origin request.
Right.
So this gives you a binary yes or no on whether your guess is lexicographically
greater or less than the target origin.
And you can then just perform a binary search on that to very, very quickly extract the full
subdomain of that, uh, target page.
Um, so not gonna lie.
It's pretty, pretty big brain dude.
And I had to read it like three times to understand it.
Um, I think there's very few situations where this will be helpful,
but one of the things they did, um, you know, mention as well is that you can use this to
determine things about the user.
Sort of like a cross site leak on whether the user is an admin or not.
Um, and that just requires, you know, you being able to do one or two of these things by.
Cause you already know the host.
Exactly.
So, so you can just hit, you know, slash slash login or whatever.
And then that makes the user redirect to either admin.localhost.com or, you know,
uh, regular user.localhost.com.
And by, you know, creating a, um, request that splits the difference between those two,
you can determine where the user landed, um, which will give you information about the user.
So there's, there's lots of sort of hackery ways that you can abuse this,
but understanding the nuances of the Chrome connection pool, um, is yet another cross site
leak vector that we have, um, in our pocket.
So I don't know if it'll be useful to anyone, but that it definitely was for this CTF.
Is it possible that I'm just wondering, like if there are ever,
um, so this can't, this doesn't do anything with parameters though, right?
No, no.
Just the host thing.
Well, if there's ever a secret stored as a sub domain, then you could binary search it out.
What I was thinking was like, if it worked in parameters, if there's ever like an endpoint
that takes a secret as a parameter, and then like does something different, if it's valid versus
if it's not, then you could binary search it to exfiltrate out the parameter.
Yeah.
There, there are some weird situations with some of Google's, um, like user generated content stuff.
That where the actual hash of the content gets placed as a sub domain and they use that as an
isolation factor.
So there, there could be some applications there.
There could be some applications in cloud where you need to know, you know, the, the sub resource
that is being loaded there.
Um, so yeah, it was, it was a cool, it was a cool one for sure.
I definitely see why it made the, the, um, the top 10.
So shout out to Salvatore and, uh, shout out to, uh, CTVB's own Jorian as well.
Uh, who was able to solve that, uh, in the CTF.
It looks like.
Hey, question.
What happens if the host also matches?
I don't know, man.
Yeah.
It's probably just some Chrome logic, right?
Maybe it becomes random or something, but I was just curious if they touch on that.
That is interesting.
I think it would actually, I think it's a hash actually.
So I think it would just overwrite, but that, that doesn't make any sense.
It would just conflict.
I don't know.
Maybe that would trigger an error or something.
Yeah.
That's an interesting edge case.
All right.
You want to jump back up to nine?
Yes.
Yep.
So, um, until we just did a whole, uh, another breakdown of this, uh, personally, me and
Justin off camera, we, where we realized the actual impact of this.
You can't call us out like that, man.
Yeah, I can't.
It's fine.
The audience needs to know the back room, the back, what's it called?
The back office talk that happens here.
Yeah.
Uh, so basically this was a, this is, um, a blog by flomb.
Um, F L O M B, um, on their blog, which is blog.flomb.net.
But, um, the connect verb, first of all, I just love like underlying stuff, right?
Like HTTP verbs and stuff like that.
For some reason, like they're just so OG and cool.
But anyways, yeah.
And you just, you don't get to use them that often.
Like when trace works, it's, uh, it's, uh, always like neat.
And so anyways, this is the connect verb.
And in HTTP one, the connect verb was just like, kind of like just a raw connection.
Everything from the client went to the server.
Everything from the server went to the client.
But what he talks about in this is how HTTP connect, HTTP two connect.
Sorry that I speak so fast listeners.
Um, it, um, it's completely different.
And so it uses this binary protocol where the fundamental unit is called a frame,
just like usual.
And the frame carries like a stream identifier.
And there's like, um, yeah, a bunch of different fields.
This is the structure of HTTP two.
Yeah.
That's right.
And it, it even like does like a, like a settings set up at the beginning.
But the TLDR is that it's complex and it's like, so there's, you know, lots of room for
new things to happen.
Basically new vulnerabilities or just new issues to happen.
I think the, uh, the, the key line is here.
I'm going to read from it.
It says streams allow multiplexing, which means a single HTTP two connection can host
multiple simultaneous connect tunnels.
Right.
Yep.
And what's really interesting is it allows you to connect to arbitrary IP and
ports through that tunnel.
So what this person did, which was they, they built a scanner and go.
And, um, even though there wasn't like good support for HTTP two yet, there is a
package and they basically Swiss army knifed what is effectively a port scanner and
full blown SSRF through the connect verb.
Um, yeah, I, I don't understand how this is not just like a straight up vulnerability.
I guess if you're supporting HTTP two, you should just block the connect verb.
Um, cause I don't even know where you would add the logic to protect against this, but, um, they show here
that whenever it's a successful connection, it shows a status 200.
If it fails, it shows a headers frame with a status 503.
And so after this, if you listen to this podcast, you should go check if any of your bug bounty
targets support the connect verb on HTTP two, because if they do, you can basically scan via
SSRF for any internal hosts.
Yeah, it was kind of weird, you know, cause we read through this thing and we're like control
F-ing for SSRF.
Like we can't find, you know, why he's not like just calling this SSRF.
And I guess it's because it is actually sort of like the intended functionality of the, you know,
HTTP server at that point.
Right.
Doing those connect things.
But I mean, if you scroll down to the bottom, he's like, yeah.
And then you can just write a raw HTTP one, you know, 1.1 request here and just request example.
Yeah.
Example.com.
Um, and that'll be returned back to you.
So, uh, definitely another attack surface here for HTTP two, um, to go after these.
Is that also basically a free proxy?
Like, could you just like use this as Tor nodes in any company that has connect turned on?
Just like, I'm sure it's rare, bro.
I'm sure it's rare.
Okay.
It's gotta be rare.
But it is, it is good to see nonetheless.
Um, so I'll definitely, uh, add that to the mass scanning for sure.
Um, all right.
Any, any final call outs on that one?
Or should I jump to the next one?
Let's move on.
All right.
Next up is the OG research, of course, that we've covered on the pod before.
Next JS, uh, pwnage by zero.
Um, like, like I said, we've covered this, but I do want to go back and kind of break it down
again because there are some things that I, I realized after looking through it, uh, as a part of the top
10 list that I think are really valuable.
Okay.
So of course, um, this research was, you know, caused a big, a big problem in the next JS community
and essentially was a cash poisoning vulnerability, um, that allowed you to just DOS any page and,
uh, later on get stored XSS, um, under a certain set of conditions.
Um, and this vulnerability breaks down to two component parts.
One, getting the route perceived as a data request, which I'll, I'll talk about in a second.
And two, making sure that the correct, uh, cache control response header was getting passed through.
And since he was able to do that, he was actually able to affect the, um, internal caching mechanism
of next JS as composed or as, uh, compared to, you know, how we're normally doing cache poisoning,
which is the difference between a CDN and a backend server, um, and break any next JS implementation
that was just sitting out there in the raw, um, which was pretty sick.
So, um, first I just wanted to double click into that, um, internal cache poisoning piece,
which is like not something that we've seen a ton of.
And these frameworks like next JS have their own internal caching mechanism sometime.
And that is what Xero is going after here.
Um, so when you're doing source code review of frameworks, uh, this is a really good thing to look at,
uh, because it can often result in, um, this sort of, uh, internal cache poisoning scenario.
And I feel like everything, everything now with AI writing code and stuff,
and then also just companies wanting to converge onto the biggest frameworks.
Things like next JS are super impactful because there's so many sites running on them.
Totally.
Yeah.
And so, I mean, targeting these frameworks as a whole, I think is just a really good idea.
And it worked out really well for him.
I think he said in here, let's see if I can find it.
Yeah.
Uh, this led to numerous reports being submitted, cumulatively amounting to a beautiful six figure sub
in bounties.
So he definitely like cleaned up with this.
Um, and so, yeah, that's the first piece is like, make sure you're looking for that internal caching
mechanism piece.
And then the other thing here, which, uh, Xero does a really good job of is looking for, um,
these internal, uh, query parameters and headers.
So next JS here is looking for this, um, uh, underscore, underscore next data request or
rec, uh, query parameter.
And that is being used to determine whether this is a data request or not.
Right.
And what, what a data request is, is a request that should be responding, you know, with,
with just the data associated with this endpoint, not the like HTML, you know, that goes back to the
user to be displayed on the page.
Yeah.
Um, and for me, that's kind of reminiscent of like the Ruby on rails, you know, dot JSON thing,
right.
Where you're able to like hit an endpoint, it'll return HTML, but then, you know, if you hit dot
JSON at the end, then it'll just dump a bunch of JSON data back to you for that endpoint.
Right.
Yep.
Yeah.
And, and so like, I feel like there's definitely other situations where this sort of data request
concept is, um, is present.
Um, so I could see that being applicable to other frameworks.
Um, and then the other, uh, thing he identified here was this X now route matches header.
And what that allowed him to do was gain control of the cache control header, um, to get a value where
he could get this actual, you know, um, data requests cached.
And, um, so as I was reading through this, I was like, yeah, but like, you know, that,
that next data request query parameter is going to be a part of the, the cache key.
And that's going to, you know, heck it up.
And that's actually a really essential part of this is that next JS is not actually considering,
uh, the query parameters as a part of the cache key.
Got it.
Um, which is, I think fairly unique, uh,
cause I think normally they are, but not in this scenario.
Um, but what comes along with that is that now you don't have a cache buster, right?
So how the heck do you not just like nuke the homepage of these websites when you're trying to
detect for this.
Right.
Um, and that's where the, uh, technique, another technique that I really liked came in,
which is, um, zero because he didn't have a, you know, cache buster that he could put in the
query parameter, he actually addressed his problem using the accepting coding header.
Um, and so the accepting coding header was a part of the cache key here.
And, uh, if we send them, I'm going to read from the, from the, um, actual right up here to address
this, we can check if the accepting coding header, uh, is a part of the cache key.
And if it is, we can send the malicious correct request without the accepting coding header,
allowing us to check if the site is vulnerable without impacting it.
Right.
Because the browser will always add that header to the request, which is going to make sure
that the normal users don't get hit with that same, uh, cache poisoned.
That's so genius.
What do you think he would have done if he didn't have that opportunity?
Yeah.
I don't know, man.
He would have had to find like, he would have just had to nuke shit left and right and things
would have been going down.
It would have been bad.
Seriously.
It's just like, oh man, how convenient.
There just happens to be a header that allows you to test this without bringing down everything.
Yeah.
No, I think that's a really great technique.
And, um, so at the end of the day, you know, what he ended up doing was, you know,
being able to hit the endpoint with the underscore, underscore next data request equals one and the X
now route matches header.
And that would return a cacheable JSON representation of that specific page.
Right.
That has some of the data passed into it.
Um, and so then that JSON representation would be cache.
Anybody going there, you know, to access the HTML version of the page would just see the,
you know, JSON version, which would cause, you know, catastrophic problems.
Right.
Um, and then later on he was actually able to get stored XSS because it was still actually
rendering that JSON with the text HTML content type since the underscore.
Oh my goodness.
Yeah, exactly.
So it's like, oh no.
Genius.
And then anything, any data passed into that, you know, JSON blob could be used to trigger.
So he said a lot of the times the user agent was actually getting passed in, you know,
into that JSON, um, and then, you know, triggering on the page
of stored XSS, which is just like an absolute nightmare situation for, for Next.js.
Absolutely insane dude.
Yeah.
So this is a really good story.
Zero puts out so much stuff.
Yeah, it's, it's good, man.
Um, it's really good stuff.
So definitely a good thing to take a look at, uh, if you're ever targeting Next.js or if you're
going to go look at a framework in general, these internal caching mechanisms, these, um, you know,
internal, uh, headers and query parameters that affect the internal functioning of these frameworks.
Really, really valuable scope.
I think.
Yeah.
Genius.
You want to jump to the next one?
Yeah.
Um, you want me to take it or you got it?
No, I'm not. I'm up next. I'm going to jump to five. Okay. All right. All right, dude. So this
is soap pwn or soap. Oh geez. I'm glad you do this straw. Yeah. I sent this to Justin. We, we got,
we kind of split this up a little bit with like server side, client side. And, uh, I claimed this
one. And then when I opened it and it was 93 pages, I sent Justin the meme of, uh, from Brooklyn
nine, nine of him going cool, cool, cool, cool, cool, cool, cool. Uh, so it happens every year,
man. I think Joel last year got like a 120 page, like paper as well that he had to go into on.net
stuff. So it's always the.net stuff. That's just so long and complicated. Yes. Um, I'm not going to
share my screen. It's 93 pages. I don't need to scroll through it, but I will, I did actually use
AI to like process it and understand it really well. And so I think that, um, yeah, so I'll give
you a good overview and if you're obsessed with.net or you think this is interesting,
then you should go dive into it. But basically actually, let me get a little bit of author
attribution here. So this is from watch tower by Piotr Basidlo. Oh dude. Yeah. This guy's a beast.
This guy's a freaking beast. Yeah. He's the principal vulnerability researcher at watchtower.
So, uh, the full title is poning.net framework application through HTTP client proxies and WSDL,
which by the way, I loved finding WSDL files back in the day, all over Yahoo. I don't really
find them much anymore, which is kind of frustrating, but did you ever run into those?
Oh yeah, dude. Those things were great. And they really just give a bunch of insight. So I'm excited
to see how he's going to handle these here. Cause I've read, I've read a bunch of his stuff,
but I have not sorted through this 93 page paper. So. Yeah. So it's a quirk in how.net handles HTTP
client proxies and then the WSDL. So the, and just upfront, I know sometimes I think things are way
more interesting when you state the, the impact first. So they downstream impact of this was arbitrary
file, right? Then NTLM like credential theft, and then actually RCE. And so, um, and there's some
drama around it, but I'll get to that in a second. So the core, the core vulnerability is basically
there's some code that is casting input into, um, and the classes that it's in it's HTTP web client
protocol, but this class is used to cast like SOAP messages into HTTP web requests. And whenever it's
initializing it or whatever, it's, it's, it's always attempting it to cast it with, uh, the as operator.
And what that means is if instead of using like an HTTP, uh, URI, you use a file or NTLM or whatever,
URI, it gets cast to a different object type. Dude, I did see this. I did see this. And here's
the really weird part is that when it fails, if it doesn't cast it, it returns null, but then it,
and then there's no checks. Oh, at the end, it does check if it's null, but if it is null,
it just skips the HTTP specific setup stuff, but continues in the rest of the flow without throwing
any other errors. So, so your, your object, which you got past all of the HTTP processing is now just
going to be processed normally by the rest of the code. And it only skipped the part that would have broken
and save the day had it actually occurred. Right. That's amazing. Yeah. So it gets cat like, so with
the file operator, it gets cast into a file web request instead of an HTTP web request. So then it
skips the HTTP processing, but then the rest of the code still basically just writes it straight to
disk. So, so you're able to write the XML straight to disk. And when you do that, um, apparently you were
able to, I didn't actually get that deep in the document, but apparently he's able to store that
as a CSHTML or an ASPX file. And so then it's just an instant web shell. And then in the, yeah,
which is amazing. Right. And then in the cases where that, where that doesn't work, you can supply
UNC path. And when the server tries to write to that UNC share, instead you get the NTLM, uh, hash,
like off hash from that request. And then you can go crack it offline. And then now you've cracked the
NTLM hash. So, um, yeah. Insane. Oh my gosh, dude, this is, yeah, this is lit. I, I, I, so I,
I realized what happened with this. There was a, you know, I don't know, friendly version of this
research that was, uh, in a, you know, in a web writeup, not like a 93, you know, page research paper.
And that was what I read. And I just, and I think we actually even covered it on the podcast where,
you know, it's just like, Oh, just like yeet this whole HTTP requested to a file, you know?
Yep. Um, so dude, I freaking love stuff like this, man. It is, uh, it is hilarious to see that this
actually worked and that it skipped that one block of code that it needed to actually break everything.
Because if it tried to parse it and it was a file instead of a web request, it would have just broken
at that point. So anyways. Wow.
All right, dude. Um, okay. So yeah, definitely, definitely gonna, uh, take a look at that again
and understand a little bit more about, um, when this is actually applicable. Uh, it, it says,
it said up here, it's basically a quirk in how .NET handles HTTP client proxy. So whenever we're
dealing with client proxies and stuff like that, that's when we should look into this and maybe get
our cherry file. Right. And I see that's crazy, man. Um, okay. Where am I jumping? I'm
Am I jumping back up to six? Yes. All right. Jumping up to six. Uh,
we actually also covered this on the pod. Um, but this is the, um, research by, uh, Kaneko Takeshi,
uh, which is cross site e-tag length leaks. Um, and I actually feel like last time on the pod,
we did a pretty good job of explaining how this works. Um, so I'm not gonna like go super in depth on
this, but I did want to highlight a couple of things that, uh, I just want to make sure you guys
understand about this because, uh, I think there are some misconceptions about how, yeah, well, I think
a lot of these things that are originating in CTFs have some pretty difficult preconditions that are,
of course, are contrived for the CTF purpose. Right. Yeah. But are not always present in, um,
in the actual, you know, exploitation scenarios. So, um, the first piece here was that, uh, if you read
this cross site e-tag length leak and had a difficult time understanding it, uh, one of the,
the, the preconditions for this attack to actually work was that you have to have a sea surf that can
allow you to control the length of the response where you are doing this, uh, you know, cross site,
um, request here. So, you know, what they do here is they use, um, let's see if I can find it here.
Uh, they use a sea surf to create notes, right. Um, which you can see right here for those of you
watching on YouTube, uh, where they, you know, but the, um, you know, the response size of their guests
right up to the, um, e-tag juncture point. And, um, the reason that's important is because the way that
this cross site leak is triggered is by creating a one byte differential in the e-tag header, right.
Um, which is, uh, returning the response of the request and then gets included by the browser in the, uh,
next request that gets sent to that same endpoint. And that one byte difference, you butt right up to
the node.js, uh, 431 maximum request size, um, uh, you know, buffer, right. Where it says, okay, we
only can have 16 kilobytes as the request size. And if you go over that, we're just going to return
a 431, right. Um, so it's very important that you have a sea surf to be able to get the response
size right up to, um, a certain juncture point where just your notes and the actual secret, if searched via
across site search will push it over that, um, juncture point with the hex representation of the content
length, uh, and create a, uh, you know, one byte difference in the e-tag header, which will then result
in the 431. Um, so it's kind of a monster to explain from a verbal perspective, but what I want
the user to understand here or the listener to understand here is that the sea surf is a really
important part of this exploit. So, um, just keep that in mind. And really what I, what I think is
more applicable for bug bounty is the Chrome, um, history API piece here, where the 431, if you're
able to trigger it, right, which is a, an error status code, um, request header fields are too large.
Um, Chrome is not embedding that, um, is not considering that as a navigation in the Chrome history
API. It is actually replacing the current navigation. So if you are able to trigger this, you will not see
a change in the history length. Uh, it will, it will just be the same. Um, and I think that is a very
applicable piece that can be used in other cross site, um, leaks, uh, in other, in other areas, um,
in other applications, that's a little bit more applicable, um, than the whole e-tag piece here.
Uh, so I know that that's a little bit complicated. Did you, did Joseph, did you get any of that or am
I just like, am I talking to the wind here? No, it's perfect. I think that I feel like you said,
the initial explanation that we did on the other episode was really, really good. And then on top of
that, I think that the clarification, the most important thing you're saying is that basically
in this case, there was like, it was a bit contrived. It's not that realistic that you'd
have CSRF where you can control the content length in that type of granularity. Um, but I do think,
I do think that really blogs like this, when you read them, what it helps you hone is your ability to
spot, um, things that should not be possible. Right. Like I think that anomalies here. Yeah.
Anomalies like, like, you know, the fact that the e-tag can like move by one character and that that's
influenceable cross site is very interesting. And I think that things like that will lead to bugs when
people are thinking about, you know, specifically like the little gadgets they have for anything that
happens cross site. That's a great point because it's actually that, and that goes to another point
that I had on this too, which is, you know, it, the e-tag header that is returned in the response,
right. Is actually getting reflected into the if none match header when you re-request the same URL.
Right. And so actually what's happening here is something that's extremely unique, which is,
you know, a response header is being reflected back into a request header. And that request header is
being used to, to, you know, overflow the request header maximum size. Right. Um, which is, I think,
very interesting and that you don't have access to that if none match header value, you know, if you did,
even though it's a part of the request, you know, you don't have access to that. Uh, you have no control
over it. That's something that's controlled by the browser. So I think that principle is a lot more,
you know, cross applicable to other, uh, exploitation scenarios probably than exactly
this e-tag scenario. Right. Yeah. So anyway, not, not, not to shit on the research at all. It is like
mind-blowingly beautiful as a client side hacker. When I read this, I, I weep tears of joy, you know,
cause I'm like, wow, what a masterpiece, what a breakdown of primitives, right? Like, you know,
and the one bite differential allows you to, you know, exploit this. Uh, so yeah, I, I think
that it still makes me very happy to read for sure. Oh yeah. It's insane. That's even possible.
Yeah. Yeah. All right. We got 20 minutes. We gotta, we gotta crank these out. Um, I have two left and
you have two left. Perfect. All right. Number four is lost in translation, exploiting Unicode normalization
by our boy, Ryan. And he also presented this to the critical thinkers, um, on top of doing it
at black at USA. So, and so, yeah, I would say go check out the recording, but I don't even know if
we recorded it cause it's on YouTube under black at USA. So the link will be in the bio, but what, uh,
Ryan and it was his daughter, right? Yeah. Yeah. Isabella as well. And we did,
we did record the critical thinkers as well. So that I don't know if it was different or what.
No, it'll be in the exclusive content in discord and it was different. So. Okay. Perfect.
Very good content there. Sweet. Yeah. Um, so anyone who has not done that, I'll do a quick overview
of basically what he, what, what they covered. Um, the first was that the agenda really is talking all
about Unicode in a Unicode normalization, but to break that down, break that down further, they talked
about decoding errors, truncation, confusables, casing, and then combining diacritics. What are you
laughing about over there? Dude. It's just such a, you know, crazy piece of research. Like,
yeah. Like you went to hear you like just rattle off those various sections to this research is like
insane. They did such a good job on it, man. Yeah. Yeah. So I think the coolest part about
the decoding errors was that they talked about over long encodings. And, uh, I loved his analogy of
basically it's like a box in a box in a box you get from, uh, Amazon or whatever. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
And so basically you can over long encode typical ASCII. So you can have an A that instead of being
one byte is two bytes or three bytes, and it's still just a normal A it's not like some weird Unicode
character. It's still just a typical A, but it's called an over long coding. And so sometimes that'll
let it bypass specific, specific regular expressions that are checking for malicious things on the, like
at the beginning before it's then decoded or normalized later. Um, and so that can be really
valuable. The second thing they talked about was byte truncation, which is where, um, certain bytes,
which are long, like the, uh, three byte Chinese character that can then be, you know, converted down
or truncated down into like a CRLF feed, um, or like a carriage return or line feed. So, um, this
specifically had a lot of impact in a bug bounty finding where, and by the way, I'm not showing
anything on screen cause it's a video, but they're, they're slide decks really good though. Um, and so
you can, uh, and they suspect, they suspected that this was due to differences between little Indian
and big ending, big Indian ordering. And, um, they show a really good example that uses a cyber chef,
um, to, to actually, you know, show how this would, would happen. Then the, that diagram, man,
that, that was such a good representation of it. I never have, I looked so closely at Unicode and felt
like I understood what I was looking at because Unicode is hacked, bro.
Dude, I actually, so hot take, I think that's why this did so well, both in the top 10 and just for
people, they finally made it super understandable. Like even just the way that I just described over
long encoding. I like, you could have talked to me about that 10 different times over the last two
years and I wouldn't remember it, but, but, but the way he described it with the boxes, it's just like,
okay, now I understand this. Right. Same for what you're talking about. Um, so then there's one
called confusables, which are, I think this is probably what most people think of when they think
of Unicode normalization. It's like these characters get confused due to like best fit mappings or worst
fit. And this is like kind of harkening back to all of the orange side research for worst fit.
Um, and they share a few more examples of that, which I thought was good. Then casing. I'd never
heard of this one until the talk, which I thought was really neat. And it's so good that they use
something. So like web app specific, they used a script tag where the I was a Latin small letter
dotless I. And then basically if the backend application did something like, um, decoded it and
then called like dot upper that, that weird dotless I becomes an I, even though it wasn't normally an I,
it now gets converted into an I. And so if there's any kind of detection logic or any kind of laugh
that's before that, it would have never been caught. But when that happens on the second half,
it actually does get caught and works quite well. Um, and then they did combining diacritics, which,
uh, to be clear is the one I understood the least, but it's also really cool. So like there's some
Unicode that's basically combining characters, for example, like greater than, and then a slash becomes
like not greater than, and then the not greater than symbol sometimes gets like, uh, converted to
greater than, which obviously when you're looking for like HTML tags or script tags, that's like when
that's really valuable. So yeah, I think that's all the things. Um, that I just wanted to add,
because I had to pull it up while you were talking about that. Like the casing thing was actually my
first introduction into, um, you know, Unicode. Oh, really? Yeah, actually it was from a live hacking
event back in like, man, it's almost 10 years ago now. And I was talking to Bit K, the researcher at
YesWeHack actually, let me flex my YesWeHack hoodie right here. And, um, and he gave me this website,
you know, that he built that showed some of the Unicode transformations on, on JavaScript, whenever
you run dot two uppercase or dot, uh, two lowercase. And, uh, you know, his handle is bit K and one of the,
the most impactful transformations is actually one of these weird Unicode Ks that I, I couldn't find the
Unicode value for in this moment. But, and if you do dot two lowercase on that, it turns to a lowercase K,
right? A lot of the other ones are like two uppercase, right? Which is a lot more rare,
but, uh, there's a ton of situations where you do dot lowercase. Yeah. Um, and so this special K will
get converted into a, uh, a lowercase K, uh, if you run dot lowercase on it. Um, yeah, so it's pretty,
it's pretty cool stuff. And I've, I've, I always thought it was awesome to do that it aligns with his name,
bit K because he can use the special K and his, as the last character. And when it gets,
uh, turned into a K. Yeah. I need to come up with a handle that, that has some like acrylics or
something in it. The, um, yeah, they, they used a K in their talk too, and it was the Kelvin K. So it
might be the same one. Oh, it might be the K. It actually looks like the Kelvin K. I gotta grab the
Unicode code point for this thing. Hold on. Yeah. Yeah. They talked specifically about Kelvin K and how
there was like some check in active scanner or something in, in verb or something that like checks for that.
Dude, I don't know how to get the Unicode code point for this quick, quick enough here.
Yeah. No, you're fine. Okay. Oh no. Yeah. So it's Unicode code point 21 to a, uh, so whatever that is.
Nice. All right. What's up next. You're up on ORM leaking more than you joined for. This is second place.
This was such, this was such cool research, man. Um, okay. I'm excited to talk about this. So we've
covered some of this research before on the podcast. I don't know whether we, uh, covered this exact one,
but after reading this, I am thoroughly convinced that ORM links are the new SQLI bro. Because if you're
looking through each one of these, um, you know, frameworks that they're just like slaughtering
in this, uh, writeup, uh, it's pretty, it's pretty gnarly. And, um, so the TLDR of the situation is you
get a lot of, um, frameworks that allow you to do, you know, filters and searches and queries and stuff
like that. And, um, depending on the way that that is implemented and mapped to SQL on the backend,
uh, there are a lot of crazy things you can do. For example, filtering, if you're searching through
users, filtering on like their password field. No. Um, yeah. And it affects a ton of different, um,
uh, ORM, um, you know, frameworks for, for all this stuff. My brain is like a slot machine,
like rolling and just thinking, or maybe a Rolodex of all the times I've had, like, um, for example,
like user, I know we're like user searches where like you put in like one or two characters and it
shows a few of them. Is that the, is that the times when this will be, will this be applicable?
Yes. Yes. And, and also, you know, you can, you can, um, also do some situations where, uh,
like if you have a field and an operation that you're able to like search on, then you can do,
for example, like password underscore underscore starts with or whatever. Um, so anyway, the,
the writeup goes through a bunch of different ways to bypass, you know, filters and blacklists for,
um, these types of, uh, ORM filters. Uh, and there's a lot of really good takeaways in there.
There's actually, uh, a section in a lot of the areas called key takeaways. Yeah. You can see right
here. I'm, I'm showing it on the screen where it talks about what things they learned about these ORM
leaks from each framework, uh, that they audited. Um, and a couple of them are, uh, that I'll,
I'll just mention right here are look for areas where you can provide a field and an operator.
Cause that really like enhances your ability to, to search. Um, definitely look for these sort of
underscore underscore situations, right? Like I've seen these inquiry parameters all the time.
Where is it right here? Me too. Yeah. Um, there it is right here, you know,
like email, email, underscore, underscore starts with or something like that. Right.
If you're seeing something like that, then that's definitely something you want to double click into.
Um, additionally, they say, even if the operator like starts with and stuff like that are not available,
don't sleep on the logical operators as well, like greater than or less than, because you can still do
sort of binary searches, right. Uh, on that, you know, using that operation. Yeah, it's huge.
Yeah. And, uh, they, they do add a whole list at the end. Let me see if I can find it. Um,
but you do run into some difficulties with that, uh, based on database collation. Um, so some of the
databases will not sort characters the way that you think they will sort characters. So, um,
you may have some difficulty performing those searches, uh, based off of, uh, the way that the
database collation works. Um, but they do some really in-depth research on each of the databases
here, MSQL, MariaDB, MySQL, um, Postgres, all of these sort of explaining how to, um, understand how
the databases compare strings, uh, if you're trying to do like a greater than or less than comparison. Um, so really
good stuff there. Some databases are also, um, like not case sensitive, which causes a problem as
well. Uh, but they have solutions for a lot of this stuff inside the article. Dude, I cannot wait to
add this as a skill to my cloud code. I'm like dying to do it right now. I'm not joking. Okay. That's
what I was saying before, um, was when I looked at this, I was like, oh man, you know, I feel like
I've seen something similar to this in this target I was hacking on. So I kicked off cloud code to go
hacking. No, I found it finishing up research and it found, I just gave it the article. I was like, Hey,
like apply some of these techniques to this host. And then it came back with a bunch of PII dude.
You know, it's crazy when you're, when you're, your cloud code just like, and here's PII. I'm like,
Oh my gosh, I love it. Mine's usually the opposite. It's like critical CSRF cores issue. And I'm like,
no, it's not shut up. No, no, no, stop. Um, the, the other big takeaway I had from this one
is that a lot of times, you know, there will be some filtering on like what, um, operations you can
use like not, or starts with or whatever. And one of the, um, tricks they gave to bypass that is if you
use the, um, sort of query parameter format of key and then square bracket, another value square packet
equals, you know, value, right. Then sometimes that will map to the JSON representation that is needed
for some of these ORM, um, operations. So the, the example they gave is reset token square bracket,
not close square bracket equals E, right. So that would map to reset in JSON, reset token colon new
object, not colon E. Yeah. Right. And, uh, and so when that, that maps out a lot of times that will allow
you to pass, uh, bypass middleware parsers for, um, sort of malicious queries going into the ORM.
Nice. Yeah. I love, uh, the way that when you convert embedded or like deep JSON back to, uh,
you're all encoded forms or whatever, not or post body forms. Yeah.
XWW form URL encoded. Yeah.
Yeah. I'll never forget that string. I'll never forget it.
Yeah. It's super useful, uh, to do those conversions. I, I still find GraphQL where,
uh, it's like you, where you don't have CSRF because it's JSON, but then you convert it and it works
fine and you have CSRF via GraphQL. Yeah. Okay. That's a good one.
Yeah. Uh, for the listener in case that wasn't super obvious, basically, uh, what we were just
talking about or not what we were just talking about, the comment I just made was for anytime you
have GraphQL, that's cookie protected and it's happening via JSON request. If you convert it to
a URL encoded form, it will, if it still works, then you have CSRF and you can just go ahead and report
that. So yeah, I mean, there's a mutation. Yeah, exactly. You have to have mutation because
otherwise it's just a get requests, which you don't, you can't, uh, see the response of.
All right. We have like five to 10 minutes left and we've got two techniques to do.
Luckily, uh, number three, which I'm doing from, uh, search, uh, server search, light cyber
team, uh, shoves his company that was acquired. Um, is, and actually, did you see like their CTO or
or something, his partner? Michael became the CEO, dude. Right. But it was, he was the CTO for
asset note. Right. And then he became. Shoves was CTO. Michael was, um, CEO of asset note. And then
he got, he became CEO of search, light cyber, which is pretty sick. So who's acquiring who I'm
the captain now. Right. Come on. Um, yeah. So we covered this actually really well back then and
it's a very short ride up. So it will, it'll take just a second here, but, uh, just as a recap,
they were, they had a blind SSRF that they wanted to escalate. And as everyone knows,
blind SSRF kind of sucks. So they were trying to make it full read. And the first thing they do
is play with redirects. And it was kind of, it was not, it was not useful. Basically they just kept
getting exception, colon, invalid JSON and they, but they increased the number of redirects. And for some
reason they could like get it to follow up to 30 and then it got a different exception. And it said like
network exception instead of invalid JSON. So that kind of got them like thinking like, oh, what
should we do here or whatever. And, um, they moved on to testing other status codes because they thought
they might be treated differently. And sure enough on a 500, it gave them the full response. So that
kind of just like got them thinking like maybe there's some way to get a full response if we do other
response codes. So they wrote a little script that would, and this is so still so confusing that it
worked. I don't know if you remember how confusing this is. Basically they had to do multiple redirects
and on each redirect, it increased the status code. So the first response was 301, then 302, then 303.
And, um, and then at the very end they would have it go to the AWS, um, metadata, I am endpoint. And
when they did that, when they hit the cloud metadata endpoint, after a bunch of those redirects,
it actually worked. And, um, and they still were like really confused just like you and I about how that
works. And I'm just going to read this paragraph because I still don't, it still doesn't really,
it's still, it's not a satisfying answer, but at least makes sense. It says, well, why did it work?
This drove us nuts. Hold up. You know, like I also just have to appreciate like whoever's writing this
here. I don't know if it's Shubs or the other people from the Asino team, but he says, this drove us
nuts. This was crazy. You know, like he's saying a bunch of things in here and it's like, it makes you feel
a little bit better that he's also like, what the frick is going on? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. This drove us nuts.
Was there something special about the 305 status code? Even though we performed a redirect from 301
to 310, why did we only get the responses starting at 305? So they ran that script. It started at 301.
It escalated up to 310 and then they had it, uh, do the, the, the redirect to the cloud metadata.
But for some reason in the final response they got, it included all of the responses, like all of the,
um, all of the redirect, uh, server side response is that include like, you know,
the, the, uh, response headers, like content type content, like connection server location.
Um, but it only started at 305. It didn't show 301 to 304, which is super confusing. So anyways,
that's why he's saying, was there something special about 305? Even though we performed a redirect from
301 to 310, why did we only get the responses from 305 and beyond? Was it an issue with libcurl?
After extensive analysis, we're convinced. No, we don't think so. Instead, we think that the application
was happy to follow a few redirects and was failing on that JSON parsing we saw initially and was not
happy about following more than max redirects configured for libcurl. However, there was an
error state when it followed more than five, not handled by libcurl, but rather by the application
itself says this technique may sound obscure to you. And I agree, but it's now worked for us in several
different situations where we would not have been able to see the full response code. I just, I'm, it's so
weird. It has to be like a configuration of a tech stack. That's not uncommon. That's like pretty
common, right? Like lots of companies are using because otherwise how would they have found it
multiple times? But anyways, this drops me nuts, but it's so freaking cool to go from a blind SRF to
a full re-SRF with this technique. Oh my gosh. Dude, like, can you just imagine, like, I'm getting
a little high from just thinking about it. Like, it's like, oh my gosh, this, uh, how much of a high it
would be to go from a blind SSRF that, and you know, I'm thinking about it in the context of the
live hack events too, where everybody's like, oh yeah, I got that blind SSRF and you go, you know,
you go there and you're like, hey, did you get anything with it? No, did you get anything with it?
And then freaking Shubs comes in. He's like, yeah, I got full read. And we're like, how did you do it?
I don't know the script. Anyways. All right, dude, we got like five minutes. Do it. Do number one.
And by the way, everyone, this is the number one voted Portswigger top 10. So yeah. Um,
really love that passive research. So fun to review that. And, uh, yeah, I'll jump to number one now.
Um, this one was really cool. And this was just really well-performed research, in my opinion.
Um, this is by vladco312. Um, and essentially is providing new techniques for exploiting, um,
SSTI. Okay. And, uh, these two techniques are called, uh, error-based exploitation and Boolean
error-based blind SSTI. And, um, he borrows a lot of the concepts for this from,
Hey, sorry, he, he just pushed improvements yesterday to this.
Oh, look at that. He did. I'm sharing my screen so we can see. Oh, wow. Dude, he's adding. Oh my gosh.
He's adding new, uh, freaking dude template. Oh my gosh. What a baller. He's adding new templates to it
right away. Uh, I guess probably something to do with, um, you know, getting in the top 10.
Um, that's amazing. So yeah, this research, dude, let me tell you, this was some of the most
thoroughly done research I've seen in a long time. Okay. Not only is he bringing two new ways to
exploit SSTI, but he's also cross-referencing this across a bunch of different templating engines,
a bunch of different programming languages, and, and providing generic payloads that work across
multiple programming languages, uh, that you can use. Amazing. That's amazing, dude. So it's freaking
sick. And he's integrating all of this into SSTI map, a tool, um, to exploit these kinds of vulnerabilities.
So, um, let me kind of go through some of these techniques. Um, a lot of you guys that are familiar
with some of the OG, you know, uh, SQLI exploitation methods will kind of, this will make a lot of sense to
you. Um, but essentially the first one is error-based exploitation and it's essentially getting,
um, and this is actually also used often in XXE, but getting, um, an error to trigger in the templating
engine and having that error displayed on the, on the screen to the user. So, uh, he was experimenting.
He kind of goes through a pretty long intro there where he talks about how he discovered this stuff.
Um, but the way he ends up, um, you know, exploiting this is, uh, triggering an error, um, using get adder in
Python, uh, which is for getting attributes and then concatting, whatever he wants the output of.
And that will, will trigger, um, an error, uh, that says, you know, string has no attribute,
whatever, right. Whatever output you passed in. And that output then in a scenario, um, you know,
the contents of Etsy password will then be leaked in that error, uh, in that actual error message.
Um, and if verbose errors are on in the application, then that full, uh, output will be displayed to the
user. Um, which is really, really helpful. Um, and he mentioned that he tried to do integer conversion
with this as well. Um, but integer conversion truncates the data at, I think, what is it like?
199 characters. Yeah. Um, but he found in Python that you can use get adder, which does not have
a limit on the amount of data that you can pass into it and leak out. Um, so he does this. I think
Python is a really good example of how to do this. Um, and he provides a sort of polyglot that works,
uh, across all tested Python based template engines, um, which was amazing. Uh, but he also provides
polyglot payloads, um, for detecting these, these error-based oracles. And for that, he does, uh,
a division by zero, um, payload. Uh, and the way that he does that is, uh, I guess, quotation mark. No,
no, no, no parentheses parentheses one divided by zero dot ZX, Y dot ZX, Y. And this will result in an
error in any programming language that he tested here. Um, and if that error comes back, then you
can use that as a way to determine, okay, wow. Um, error-based oracles for SSTI in this scenario is
kind of the way to go. And then you, you pick from the variety of, uh, you know, error-based payloads
he gives you in Python, PHP, Java, Ruby, Node.js, Elixir, all of these. Um,
so can we respect the fact that he's doing a lot of this testing via some sort of like discord bot?
Is he knows that there's a bunch of the screen, there's a bunch of the screenshots where
like go to the, go to like the, Oh yeah, yeah. He's doing like slash test and then putting in some
content and then it's doing some sort of test under the hood and then it's showing him the response.
He's like testing stuff from discord. I love it. What a badass man. Yeah, dude. This is exactly
how you use cloud code too. You, you just like, uh, just talk to it all the time in discord, which is
great. Um, so that was the error-based exploitation. We see similar stuff in XXE error-based, um, you know,
leaks for XXE. Um, and then the second type he mentioned was Boolean error-based blind SSTi.
Okay. And this is a similar situation where, um, you've got an error-based SSTi, but it's resulting
only in a 500 from the server. Right. Um, so what he does here is use a similar concept with, you know,
one divided by some expression and that expression should be cast or evaluate to zero. And if it does,
then it triggers a divide by zero exception and will cause a 500 from the server. And so using that,
you have a Boolean yes or no. Did my expression resolve to zero? Uh, and that can allow you to leak
valuable data in the application when you have the full set of SSTi, um, expressions at your disposal.
Um, so he also provides some generic detection payloads for this. Uh, these ones actually take
advantage of, uh, syntax errors for generic detection. Um, those are located at the bottom
of the article. Um, I, I won't read them out because it's just going to be hard to like explain
to you that there's syntax errors here, but for any of those of you watching on YouTube, you guys can
clearly see the syntax errors in the location of the print or the, um, yeah, parentheses in this, uh,
in this expression, which will trigger the, the error message, um, whenever you're using your scanner.
So very thoroughly done research, um, built it into a tool, documented all of the nuances in
different programming languages. There's no wonder this was number one. No wonder. It's so good in
every way. It makes me want to go test for it everywhere. It's like insane. Dude. I, I very rarely
find SSTi. I think that is one area where I really need to improve as a hacker is looking for SSTi, because it's so
valuable too. Um, all right. Shout out to Vladco for that. Um, I did want to say, I know you got to go,
Joseph, so feel free to drop if you need to, but I did have one little quick story. I actually combined
the ORM research with this blind Boolean error-based attack one time, and I kind of wanted to tell them
about it. So I'm going to do a quick little story here. So, um, I was testing an application where I had
a secondary context path traversal, and I've talked about this on the pod before, uh, this specific instance.
I won't tell you which one, but, um, we had a secondary context path traversal, and I was actually able to
inject Microsoft graph, uh, OData, um, filters, um, in there. And this allowed me to do stuff like, okay, if
username equals Reinerader, then, you know, return that in the response, right? Uh, apply filters there.
So they patched that whole thing and made it so that I couldn't get the data back out, but I knew
that I was still getting this OData injection, right? In the backend. Yeah. So what I ended up doing was
crafting an OData query, um, where, you know, it was like, starts with a specific ID and username is
equal to whatever user I wanted to target. Uh, first name is equal to this or divide by zero, right?
Divide it, you know, ID by zero. And so if, you know, if the first name started with whatever,
right, then it would not hit that second divide by zero condition, divide the ID by zero. But if it
didn't, then I w I would hit it and it would trigger an error. Right? So, and I was able to detect that
error out through the secondary context path traversal because it was reflecting error conditions back up.
Sure. Yeah. Even though it blocked the JSON response. Um, so using that, we were able to also
arbitrarily leak data. Oh my God. The fact that the fact that you and him both converged on a divide by zero
payload, like just goes to show that you're all genius. I think personally, I just think that's
like really neat that both of your all's heads, like that two people who are really intelligent
who are looking at this, like similar problem came to the same conclusion is like very cool.
Yeah. Yeah. I like it too. It's very valuable for triggering error based, uh, oracles in my opinion.
So, all right, man, GG. I think that's a wrap on port swigger top 10. Yeah. Perfect. Yep. Peace.
All right. Peace y'all. And that's a wrap on this episode of critical thinking. Thanks so much for
watching to the end y'all. If you want more critical thinking content, uh, or if you want to support the
show, head over to ctbb.show/discord. You can hop in the community. There's lots of great high
level hacking discussion happening there on top of the masterclasses, hack alongs, exclusive content,
and a full-time hunters guild. If you're a full-time hunter, it's a great time. Trust me. I'll see you there.